إنها بداية نوبة عمل مدتها 24 ساعة
للمسعفين ألكسندر رودكوفسكايا وفلاديمير وينزل ،
حيث
يقومون بإعداد سيارة الإسعاف الخاصة بهم
للمذبحة التي يواجهها سكان هاركيف
كل يوم ،
ولدينا عاصبتان فلاديمير تقول
والدة ألكسندرا تتوقف عند مركز الإرسال
لإعطاء ابنتها عناقًا.
واحدة من أخطر الوظائف في
كل لحظة معًا هي ثمينة
تدفق عالٍ من إشارات الازدهار إلى أن
عمل اليوم قد بدأ
، والآن يخبرنا عامل الإسعاف هذا أن
ألكسندر وفلاديمير يجيبان على
درجة حرارة المكالمة التي تقول إن الكود المستخدم عندما
أصيب شخص ما
بقصفه  السترات الواقية من الرصاص جاهزة
للطرح ،
لذا قالوا إنهم نسوا التقارير التي تفيد بأن
شخصًا واحدًا على الأقل قد أصيب
في القصف وأنهم يسمعون بعض
الصواريخ أيضًا ، لذا سنرى ما يحدث
على القذائف  أصاب مبنى سكني
يحتاج المسعفون إلى التحرك بسرعة.
تضرب القوات الروسية بشكل متزايد نفس
الهدف مرتين
يطلق عليها د  انقر نقرًا مزدوجًا على إستراتيجية مروعة
لإخراج عمال الإنقاذ أثناء
استجابتهم لأننا نرى
أنفسنا في
أسرع وقت ،
فأنت تختبئ تحت بئر السلم
تحاول ألكسندرا العثور على الشخص الجريح
ولكن لا توجد إشارة
في تلك اللحظة إلى وابل آخر
[موسيقى]
دعامة للتأثير
هي أن الجميع بخير تطلب
ألكسندرا من عضو فريقنا ماريا أبديفا أن تقطع
يديها على الزجاج المكسور ،
يعالج فلاديمير إصاباتها بينما
يتصل ألكسندر بالرسالة مرة أخرى
للعثور على مكان الجرحى
[موسيقى
] الاتصال ينقطع باستمرار
أخبرني بمنزلك اللعين  رقم تقول
أنا أكرر 12 جرامًا ، لقد أخبرتك ألف
مرة أنه يرد على الرجل يحتضر ،
قررنا أن نحاول الجري من أجله ،
واحد اثنان ثلاثة ،
هيا ماريا ماريا ،
هيا يا ماريا ،
هيا ، هيا ،
تمضي
حسنًا ، لذلك نحن  كانوا للتو في مبنى سكني
أه كانوا يبحثون عن رجل مصاب
جاءت مجموعة من الطلقات وضربت
مبنى المتجر التالي ، لذلك نحن الآن
نخرج بأسرع ما يمكن
بينما ننفد.  ركض ديمير وألكسندرا عائدًا إلى الداخل ،
ووجدناهم يعالجون الرجل المصاب
على جانب الطريق ،
وقد تحطمت نافذتهم الخلفية
بسبب الانفجارات
، فقد أصيب بشظايا وصدمة في الرأس
بمجرد أن يثبوا استقراره ، واندفعوا
إلى المستشفى
يسأل فلاديمير عن ذلك.  ألمه ولكن
الرجل أصيب بالصمم بسبب الانفجار الذي
وصل إلى المستشفى ، لقد قاموا
بدورهم ،
الأمر متروك للآخرين الآن لإنقاذه.
سألهم لماذا
يستمرون في القيام بهذا العمل ،
هذا هو عملنا بالطبع إنه مخيف
كما هو الحال بالنسبة للجميع تقول ألكسندرا
اليوم أنك كنت معنا في المكان الأكثر سخونة
في الفرن ولكننا ما زلنا على قيد الحياة
الحمد لله
لا تشعر أنه واجبك أو
يقول لنا فلاديمير أن نساعد
الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا
هنا وماذا يقول والداك ماذا
يقول عائلتك ألا يريدونك
أن تتوقف عن هذا العمل
لا تعليقات
لا من الصعب جدًا
أن تكون
خائفًا نعم نعم فخور ولكن ندبة  إد أوه كولا طوال
النهار طوال الليل
ماذا يعني أننا رأينا والدتك
نعم
إنها قلقة لدرجة
الهستيريا تخبرنا ألكسندرا أنها تقول إنك بحاجة إلى
المغادرة وتحتاج إلى الذهاب إلى مكان آمن
لماذا تفعل هذا لدي طفل واحد فقط
توقف  تقول ببساطة ، وماذا تقول ،
يجب أن أفعل ذلك
، وبهذا يعودون لتنظيف
سيارة الإسعاف
الخاصة بهم فقط في منتصف الطريق.